vous venez de le voir avec ce
documentaires des milieux au sacchéty 11
ans après la mort de Mohammar Kadhafi et
malgré de multiples tentatives de
médiation la Libye demeure aujourd'hui
fragmenté gangrené par la violence ou
tribu Émilie se disputent inlassablement
le pouvoir politique et la manne du
pétrole existe-t-il un moyen de mettre
un terme à cette guerre sans fin en
Libye une guerre ou par le biais de
l'OTAN les États-Unis la Grande-Bretagne
et la France ont allumé la mèche sans
parvenir jusqu'ici à l'état nous allons
en débattre maintenant avec nos invités
présents sur ce plateau de débat doc
avec vous pour commencer j'allais leur
chaoui bienvenue à vous vous êtes
chercheur au sein du Royal United
service institut de le Russie et vous
êtes bien sûr un spécialiste du sujet
qui nous concerne aujourd'hui autrement
dit la Libye Isabelle Lasserre est
également avec nous bienvenue vous êtes
rédactrice en chef adjointe au service
international du Figaro en charge des
questions de diplomatie puis à vos côtés
Patrick
mzad bienvenue à vous vous êtes ancien
diplomate français basé à Tripoli et
auteur de au cœur de la Libye de Kadhafi
c'est un ouvrage qui a été publié chez
Jean-Claude latesse on va regarder un
tout petit peu dans le rétroviseur après
ce documentaire et comme l'a fait
d'ailleurs ce documentaire il nous a un
manquement ramené à 2011 cette
intervention de de l'OTAN sous l'égide
de l'Otan avec en tête de pont les
États-Unis la Grande-Bretagne et la
France on a l'impression bien entendu
après avoir vu ce film que c'est une
guerre sans fin et que à l'époque ces
trois pays majeurs dont la France
n'avait imaginé à aucun moment une
solution politique pour la pré-cadhafi
11 ans après c'est bien c'est bien de
constat qu'on fait après avoir vu ce
documentaire ce que j'ai beaucoup aimé
dans le documentaire c'est que la
chercheuse Virginie Colombier a insiste
bien sur le rôle des États arabes
notamment le Qatar les Émirats arabes
unis la Jordanie mais aussi le rôle
longitaire de l'Arabie Saoudite il y
avait cette volonté arabe d'intervenir
contre moi marcada fille c'est ce qui
explique que la Chine et la Russie se
sont abstenus au Conseil de sécurité ça
explique aussi pourquoi l'Afrique du Sud
le Nigéria et d'autres pays se sont
absolus donc j'ai été un petit peu par
exemple chagriné par la version un petit
peu
incompatible avec la narration russe qui
a été véhiculée par Edwy Plenel qui dit
que
ce qui avait été proposé le 17 mars 2011
était un texte mensongé c'est pas vrai
le texte était tout à fait transparent
les les avertissements américains juste
avant le vote avec été extrêmement
sincère assez très franc il avait été
dit de manière très claire que moi
marcadafi elle allait sans doute pas
survivre à l'intervention militaire donc
le côté un petit peu malhonnête de cette
de cette résolution de 2011 c'est
quelque chose qui a été un petit peu
fabriqué par les Russes dès cette
année-là alors que les Russes eux-mêmes
c'était abstenus donc il faut quand même
garder un regard historique factuel et
non pas forcément être séduit par ces
espèces d'interprétation politique
la Russie jusqu'à ce jour là
Isabelle Lasserre café la France qu'on
fait les États-Unis qu'on fait la
Grande-Bretagne après cette guerre pour
imaginer une solution politique à la
pré-cadhafi pas grand chose non mais
c'est pas le c'est pas uniquement le cas
de la Libye c'est-à-dire que en Libye
comme d'ailleurs en Afghanistan et comme
en Irak on a là la limite du modèle
militaire c'est-à-dire que l'Occident
quand il livre des guerres depuis
un certain nombre d'années réussi à les
gagner militairement mais ne réussit pas
à gagner la paix en fait gagner la paix
c'est ce qui est le plus difficile c'est
ce qui s'est passé en Irak il y a
immédiatement l'esprit par exemple et
puis même l'Afghanistan ou après
l'intervention américaine les Américains
ont délaissé l'Afghanistan pour investir
davantage en Irak et finalement ont dû
partir en août l'année dernière et
laisser les talibans revenir donc il y a
eu des interventions militaires qui ont
relativement fonctionné par exemple
celle de l'OTAN contre la Serbie de
milocewitch pour défendre le Kosovo mais
elles sont rares mais si on parle aussi
d'histoire je pense qu'il y a une autre
il y a une autre leçon de cette crise
libyenne enfin guère libyenne qui est
très important c'est parce qu'elle elle
entre en
haut parleur il y a un haut-parleur de
ça en Ukraine c'est que en Irak comment
Libye comme en Ukraine on a trois pays
qui ont un moment donné de leur histoire
politique acceptée de se débarrasser de
leurs armes nucléaires et ces trois pays
ont subi des agressions et les deux et
les deux leaders de ces de trois de ces
pays ont disparu et ça c'est très
important parce que aujourd'hui de
nombreux pays regardent ça l'Iran
regarde ça en accélérant sa marche vers
la vers la bombe nucléaire en refusant
de revenir dans la console nucléaire de
2015 et après une possibilité de
prolifération nucléaire dans la région
avec des pays sunnites qui pourraient
être tentés comme l'Arabie Saoudite
l'Egypte ou la Turquie de suivre le pas
donc il y a pas uniquement une leçon
militaire mais aussi il y a aussi cette
leçon
qui moi me paraît très importantes
aujourd'hui
oui alors il y a plusieurs choses je
voudrais dire d'abord bon moi je fais
partie des gens qui en 2011 était contre
l'intervention militaire en France on
n'était pas si nombreux que ça parce
qu'il y avait souvenez-vous il y avait
un consensus dans la classe politique et
médiatique pour pour y aller non pas que
j'étais un admirateur du régime de
Kadhafi mais parce que justement je
pensais qu'il y avait c'était
effectivement ouvert la boîte de Pandore
alors il faut savoir que l'Occident au
sens large nous savons détruire des
états on a prouvé plusieurs fois mais
nous sommes incapables de reconstruire
des états et ça toute toute on pouvait
nous dire il fallait envoyer des hommes
sur le terrain il fallait penser l'après
c'est extrêmement difficile sauf
recoloniser le pays ou lui imposer un
protectorat ou un mandat comme on l'a
fait d'ailleurs au Kosovo ça nécessite
des dizaines de milliers d'hommes sur le
sur le terrain et des mandats des
Nations Unies donc je pense que en 2011
Nicolas Sarkozy dès le départ a fermé la
porte à une à une possibilité de
négociation politique en disant même pas
une semaine après le début de
l'insurrection Kadhafi n'est plus un
interlocuteur donc à partir de ce
moment-là on a refusé de parler à ses
émissaires et on a favorisé l'option
militaire en reconnaissant comme seul
interlocuteur légitime les insurgés et
en allant vers la guerre qui finalement
le 19 mars a été que la continuation de
ce que j'appelle la logique de guerre
voilà quand on refuse de parler à
quelqu'un alors c'est intéressant parce
que finalement on avait d'un autre côté
l'Union africaine imaginez en tout cas
côté français à l'époque c'était le CNT
le fameux CNT le Conseil voilà national
de transition c'est ça l'alternative
mise en avant par le pouvoir français
par Nicolas Sarko tout à fait et qui
voulait dire la fin donc à partir du
moment où on prend ce type de décision
on radicalise dans les deux camps les
plus extrémistes les plus vaste en
guerre parce qu'il y avait bien sûr dans
les deux camps des gens qui voulaient
négocier la Libye c'est un village tout
le monde se parle les gens sont pas
nombreux et donc on pousse on pousse au
bout cette logique le gars et on ferme
les portes de la diplomatie qui par
exemple était mise en avant par l'Union
africaine alors c'est d'autant plus
intéressant là on fait une boucle
directement avec ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui c'est clair récemment le
nouvel envoyé spécial des Nations Unies
c'est un c'est un Africain c'est un
Sénégalais il faut savoir que l'Union
africaine avait proposé une médiation
représentant des Nations Unies depuis 11
ans en Libye ça prouve à quel point les
Nations Unies ont des difficultés à
instaurer un dialogue sur place se
représentant sénégalais dont vous parlez
il vient d'être nommé mais c'est le 8e
oui c'est le 8e et bah alors bien sûr il
faut là aussi on peut pas rejeter
entièrement la faute sur les les Nations
Unies les Nations Unies c'est aussi le
reflet de la volonté des états et on a
bien vu Hassan il explique dans le
documentaire c'est que au même moment ou
un certain nombre de pays y compris au
niveau des membres permanents du Conseil
de sécurité faisait valoir la stabilité
et la marge vers les élections c'est
même pays se divisaient et armés un camp
ou l'autre des différents protagonistes
libres
vous les compléter quelque chose oui
avant de passer à la situation
d'aujourd'hui je pense qu'il faut éviter
un regard trop déterministe par rapport
à 2011 c'est-à-dire le l'histoire ne
s'est pas arrêté en 2011 il y a eu
beaucoup d'actions fraîches notamment à
ce que Patrick vient de souligner c'est
à dire des interventions renouvelées
toujours très imaginatif certaines qui
ont qu'on arrête d'imaginative c'est
vrai sans doute mais enfin aujourd'hui
on a un pays qui est coupé en deux
oui tout à fait deux chefs de
gouvernement deux Parlement de banque
centrales ans après des milliers de
morts à travers plusieurs séquences de
guerre civile c'est comme ça qu'on doit
l'appeler deux armées deux armées un
échec complet
il n'y a pas la guerre il n'y a pas la
guerre depuis quasiment 30 mois il faut
le noter c'est pas il y a pas il y a
personne qui là au moment où je vous
parle personne n'est en train d'être tué
par des des frappes aériennes quand ça a
été le cas notamment en 2019-2020 et
j'avais encore 38 mois dans les
faubourgs
noter la différence et aujourd'hui c'est
beaucoup plus une crise cleptocratique
politique qu'une crise militaire ou
sécurité daesh est très faible
aujourd'hui par exemple l'État islamique
est très faible aujourd'hui en Libye
même la crise migratoire n'est pas aussi
grave qu'elle n'était avant juillet 2017
par exemple moment où les Italiens sont
intervenus avec succès finalement donc
il faut quand même relativiser c'est pas
c'est pas Mad Max qu'est-ce qu'on peut
dire sur cette c'est pas si on ne se
payer en deux
exécutifs de banque centrale avec du
côté de l'ouest et de Tripoli et ce
gouvernement reconnu par les Nations
Unies aujourd'hui Abdelhamid
et puis de l'autre côté
Fati bachaga qui est soutenu par le
fameux maréchal Haftar dont on a
évidemment suivi l'évolution tout au
long du film que nous venons de voir
alors moi ce que ce que j'ai envie de
dire en fait c'est que au-delà de la
division de des deux factions et entre
l'est et l'ouest de la Libye il y a
plusieurs guerres en fait dans cette
crise libyenne enfin en tout cas il y a
plusieurs affrontements qui ont été des
guerres il y a l'affrontement entre la
Turquie et la Russie il y a
l'affrontement entre la Turquie et les
Émirats arabes unis l'Arabie Saoudite il
y a eu un moment donné un affrontement
diplomatique entre la France et l'Italie
en fait c'est une guerre un petit peu
par de procuration procuration
dans ce pays qui est un pays Carrefour
et extrêmement important parce qu'il y a
ces richesses pétrolières parce que
il contrôle une partie de la
Méditerranée et parce qu'il y a cette
question migratoire et parce que aussi
stratégiquement ça c'est pour les Russes
et pour les Turcs c'est vraiment c'est
un pont c'est un pont vers à la fois
vers la Méditerranée et vers l'Afrique
pour les Russes en fait tout le monde
est présent dans cette pauvre Libye donc
et tout le monde s'affrontent et les
intérêts s'affrontent et on n'a pas tenu
compte pendant très longtemps enfin en
tout cas c'est puissance là défendent
d'abord leurs intérêts je parle
notamment par des Turcs et des Russes
avant de défendre les intérêts libyens
donc c'est extrêmement compliqué à
dénouer en fait et là ça et en plus ça
change c'est à dire que là à la faveur
de la guerre en Ukraine c'est pas le cas
que de la Libye mais c'est aussi le cas
de certains pays d'Afrique aussi de la
Syrie mais il y a eu un allègement de la
présence militaire russe parce que les
Russes ont besoin de renforcer le front
ukrainien et donc une consolidation
automatiquement du front turc et de la
et de la présence politique turque donc
vous voyez bien c'est pas c'est
tellement compliqué et emmêler
j'ai beaucoup de choses à dire d'abord
je suis tout à fait d'accord avec ce
qu'a dit Jalal on n'a pas de guerre
depuis 11 ans on a une crise politique
et des blocages politiques avec
effectivement des séquences
d'affrontements armés puisqu'il n'y a
pas d'état fort pour l'instant en mesure
de contrôler le pays par contre là
effectivement on a beaucoup cité
a beaucoup cité la Russie et Turquie bon
on oublie je sais pas si c'est
volontaire mais on oublie la France et
l'Egypte il faut savoir que la France
le gouvernement
diplomatiquement le gouvernement légal
qui était à Tripoli et en même temps on
a soutenu militairement le maréchal qui
ne l'oublions pas à attaquer Tripoli
donc quelqu'un
Le Drian je crois à l'époque
et voir Khalifa et lui a dit ce que
c'est vous qui l'avez je vous cite
puisque vous l'avez dit dans votre
article
quand a dit vous avez tardé à venir me
voir Le Drian lui a dit j'attendais vos
victoires Monsieur le Maréchal donc on
peut effectivement s'interroger sur la
politique française depuis toutes ces
années en libidon il y a effectivement
les Turcs et les Russes qui sont nos
meilleurs nos meilleurs ennemis qu'on
aime montrer du doigt mais il y a aussi
nous-mêmes on a joué un rôle il y a
aussi l'Egypte notre notre bon allié
militaire le maréchal Sissi et puis à un
moment donné les Émirats arabes unis qui
qui ont aussi qui ont aussi joué leur
carte du côté du maréchal donc je pense
que tout le monde
a joué ses cartes en Libye encore
récemment la France soutenait Fathi
bachara on a joué cette carte là aussi
au risque effectivement de d'encourager
cette personne dans dans l'idée qui
pouvait rentrer dans Tripoli et on a vu
ce que ça donnait au mois d'août vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure vous-même 38
mois donc donc voilà donc effectivement
quand on parle de ces 11 ans je pense
que tous ces pays ont joué contre leur
intérêt parce qu'effectivement ce n'est
l'intérêt de personne d'avoir une Libye
telle qu'elle est à l'heure actuelle ni
en termes économique parce que il y a
des immenses contrats de reconstruction
dans ce pays ni en termes de stabilité
vous avez parlé des migrations c'est un
bon exemple le Sahel également puisque
l'armée française était présente et
encore au Sahel on va remplir sur ce
terrain de l'immigration quelques 500
000 personnes candidates individu
candidat à l'immigration qui sont passés
par justement la Libye pour arriver en
Europe c'est considérable oui c'est
considérable effectivement potentiel
du côté de la Libye la question
l'immigration bon effectivement c'est un
pays qui est immense avec de grandes
étendues désertiques sans État donc il y
a un certain nombre d'acteurs bien sûr
sécuritaire et économique qui profitent
qui profitent de de ces flux migratoires
et je citerai aussi que l'Union
européenne finalement à financer un
certain nombre de groupes armés ça a été
démontré très bien dans un article
récent je crois dans le New Yorker par
un journaliste américain
qu'effectivement les fonds de l'Union
européenne avaient servi à financer des
groupes armés et aussi la marine la
marine libyenne qui finalement récupère
c'est malheureux parfois à la limite des
eaux territoriales voire à l'extérieur
des hôtels libyennes pour les ramener
dans des camps où on sait qui sont
effectivement maltraités donc de ce côté
là il y a aussi beaucoup de choses à
dire cette guerre procuration pour
reprendre ce terme et nous ramener sur
ce terrain évoqué par Isabelle Lasserre
il y a un moment qu'on comprenne bien le
elle se joue entre qui et qui cette
guerre par procuration entre grande
nation on évoque la donc la Russie la
Turquie qui sont plutôt du côté du
pouvoir légal qui se trouve être Tripoli
dans la rue et les autres soutiennent le
pouvoir situer à l'est du pays c'est
très bien que vous ayez introduit cette
notion de Gap à procuration maintenant
il faut quand même dire que il y a il y
a des films
des des ce sont pas des représentants
idéaux des différents états par exemple
il y a des tensions qui sont évoquées
régulièrement par le maréchal à la star
concernant sa relation avec les Russes
et il a raison les Russes ne sont pas
des parents agréables par rapport au
maréchal Astar en revanche il
fournissent une protection par rapport à
ces territoires qui qui est vital pour
sa survie et en même temps ils exigent
d'être payé régulièrement donc c'est
vraiment c'est pas des des romances
c'est pas des histoire d'amour et les
Turcs aussi sont très durs par rapport
au gouvernement de Tripolis ils exigent
des promesses de contrats des accords
maritimes et ainsi de suite ils le font
toujours dans des moments de faiblesse
il y a aussi des États qui changent de
côté ça il faut le dire les Émirats
arabes unis étaient du côté du maréchal
à latin aujourd'hui ils sont assez à
l'aise avec le rival du maréchal afta à
Tripoli donc il y a ça rappelle que la
Libye n'a pas de division sectaire il
n'y a pas de grands problèmes religieux
au sens où on pourrait le voir en Syrie
au Yémen donc il est toujours il y a
toujours cette option de changer de
retourner sa verse sa veste pendant deux
ans et revenir et alors sur cette
échiquier qu'on comprenne bien où on est
la France aujourd'hui la France je
dirais que depuis 2014 à une sympathie
presque organique pour l'autoritarisme
du maréchal afta il y a deux
otaritarisme
proclamée par rapport à un autoritarisme
un peu plus dur que celui des Turcs un
peu plus
un peu plus vertical un peu plus
tyrannique qui correspond un peu plus au
modèle égyptien si vous voulez qui est
aimé par l'Arabie Saoudite la France a
une espèce de compassion de sympathie
pour ce cet autoritalisme là et non pas
celui de d'erdohan par exemple président
turc
oui alors c'est pas avoué comme ça du
côté français mais de facto on voit moi
je me souviens quand j'avais été avec
l'ancien ministre Jean-Yves Le Drian à
la fois à Tripoli
voir Sarah le Premier ministre de
l'époque et voir Haftar on voyait la
différence de de d'attitude du ministre
français qui était très
mal à l'aise à Tripoli on voyait bien
que les choses étaient contraintes il y
avait beaucoup de sécurité ça se passait
pas très bien et avec aftard c'était un
petit peu la camaraderie c'était avant
son son offensive militaire et
apparemment d'ailleurs il n'avait pas
prévenu son homologue français qui
pourtant qui pourtant le soutenait c'est
vrai qu'il y a cette attirance française
pour ce qui est censé représenter
l'ordre la verticale du pouvoir c'est
pareil avec Vladimir Poutine il n'y a
pas de sympathie mais on est la France
est souvent attirée c'est restent de
jacobinismes peut-être par les par le
par ce qui représente par les États
forts par les
l'autoritarisme et le pouvoir vertical
bon maintenant c'est
les efforts diplomatiques de la France
enfin la France a plusieurs fois depuis
l'arrivée d'Emmanuel Macron à
Celle-Saint-Cloud quand il a fait se
réunir les deux frères ennemis ici
jusqu'aux efforts récents l'année
dernière la France a quand même le but
de la France était quand même de les
faire se réunir et de tenir une
réconciliation à chaque fois ça a été
des coûts diplomatiques mais il y a pas
non plus un soutien du maréchalaftar
comme par exemple comme par exemple la
Russie soutient le maréchalaftar il y a
eu un moment maréchal Astar et puis ce
moment c'est bien arrêté au moment a
voulu prendre Tripoli c'était en 2020
aujourd'hui son étoile un peu Palio
général afta moi je pense je pense qu'on
a vraiment on a vraiment soutenu
sérieusement à la meilleure preuve c'est
qu'on qu'on l'avait déconseillé
militaires il y a des hommes de la DGSE
qui sont morts en service en combattant
aux côtés du maréchal eftar on a livré
des missiles Javelin et qui ça fait une
grosse affaire parce que c'est des
biciles Américains qui sont trouvés
ensuite dans les mains de du
gouvernement de Tripoli parce que les
les attaquants de FFTA abandonnés donc
on a été très loin quand même dans ce
dans ce soutien alors oui je pense
qu'effectivement il y a une fascination
pour les régimes militaires on a un
certain nombre de nos responsables il y
a une peut-être une difficulté à
appréhender
on parle souvent de chaos de milice de
tout ça la situation
sociologique à l'ouest qui effectivement
est plus proche de ce qu'on pourrait
appeler chez nous
une recherche de consensus s'il y a des
équipes de force des alliances
changeantes donc il y a des débats à
l'est c'est vraiment un système
pyramidal militaire donc je crois qu'il
y a une et c'est pour avoir accompagné
des ministres enfin dans quand j'étais
diplomate je sais qu'il y a une facilité
pour beaucoup de nos responsables
politiques à mieux aborder des
militaires d'autant plus que le Drian
était ministre de la Défense auparavant
les intérêts français aujourd'hui en
Libye ils se résument à quoi aujourd'hui
les intérêts français qu'on est encore
présents sur dans ce pays je pense qu'on
a été extrêmement
décrédibilisé
aux yeux de beaucoup de Libyens
notamment à l'ouest à l'est à l'est
également je suis pas persuadé qu'on est
un potentiel ou un énorme de je dirais
de sympathie maintenant il y a des
entreprises françaises qui étaient
présentes avant avant 2011 donc il y a
des contrats qui qui pourraient être
renouvelés et il y a surtout un marché
énorme de reconstruction dans le secteur
hospitalier dans le secteur électrique
dans lesquels on a on a une expertise
mais c'est tout ça est potentiel et
dépendra bien sûr de de mes
politiquesment je pense qu'on est
actuellement
assez marginalisé
sur la sur la scène libyenne pour le
moment on va avoir un extrait si vous
voulez bien du documentaire à propos
d'un élément clé évidemment en Libye et
dans cette crise libyenne il s'agit du
pétrole
avec plus de 48 milliards de barils le
pays possède les réserves de pétrole les
plus importantes en Afrique et se place
au neuvième rang mondial avec un tel
potentiel énergétique et une population
d'environ 7 millions d'habitants la
Libye pourrait ressembler à un pays
comme la Norvège et l'AS ces champs de
pétrole sont désormais pris en otage par
des milices et des mercenaires tandis
que les systèmes d'approvisionnement en
électricité et en eau potable sont
régulièrement sa beauté
première réserve africaine le pétrole
libyen 9ème puissance pétrolière au
monde qui contrôle aujourd'hui le
pétrole libyen le maréchal afta de
manière assez claire il y a quelques il
y a quelques atouts pétroliers
stratégiques qui sont un petit peu
contrôlés par le ces rivaux à Tripoli
mais l'immense majorité et contrôlé par
le maréchaltar c'est pour ça d'ailleurs
qu'on a eu droit à une blocus qui a duré
90 jours d'avril à juillet 2022 en
pleine crise ukrainienne à l'époque le
prix du pétrole était encore plus élevé
qu'aujourd'hui et pourtant les
États-Unis sont restés silencieux face à
un mariage Haftar qui est qui dont on
connaît la proximité avec les Russes a
décidé de manière unilatérale de
d'imposer ce blocus qui a coûté à sa
propre à son propre pays des milliards
et des milliards donc il y a ce chantage
constant et il peut y avoir encore un
nouveau blocus cette année avant la fin
2022 donc c'est c'est quelque chose
d'omniprésent si vous voulez dans les
dans les instruments de négociation un
petit peu un petit peu voilà hostile
dans dans surtout dans l'attitude du
maréchal after celui qui détient le
pétrole en Libye fait
un grand pas vers le pouvoir politique
en Libye c'est comme ça que les choses
se passent ou pas du tout sinon
mettre un contesté de tout le pays mais
par contre les questions énergétiques
comme le pétrole sont un élément
fondamental de la Libye ils expliquent
notamment
que tout un tas de pays soit présent
soit présent en Libye pas plus tard que
la semaine dernière d'ailleurs il y a eu
un nouvel accord entre la Turquie et la
Libye sur la prospection des
hydrocarbures dans la Méditerranée ça
aussi ça ça a des implications à la fois
vis-à-vis de de la Grèce qui était au
Bizzbee avec la Turquie notamment sur
cette question
d'hydrocarbures de la Méditerranée et et
au sein de l'Union européenne donc la
question énergétique elle est elle est
présente dans absolument
toutes les forces qui qui se battaient
et qui aujourd'hui tente d'influencer la
scène politique libyenne et hormis le
général le maréchal à la star qui
bénéficie de cette manne pétrolière
libyenne aujourd'hui
en fait ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que
les revenus du pétrole de toute façon
même s'ils sont contrôlés des facto par
les troupes fidèles au maréchal liftar
vont ensuite sont inverser dans les
caisses de la Banque centrale et c'est
l'état libyens qui est laquelle de
banque centrales parce qu'il y en a deux
banques centrales de Tripoli de Tripoli
alors je crois oui pour on a un petit
peu pour pour passer il y a deux petites
choses que je voudrais redire par
rapport à ce qui était dit précédemment
sur la aussi tordre le coup un peu à
cette idée de d'une division Est-Ouest
je pense que c'est plus compliqué que ça
par exemple le Premier ministre
nommé par l'est en l'occurrence c'était
quelqu'un administrata de l'Ouest qui
est de la même ville que Monsieur
Abdelhamid Biba qui est le chef du
gouvernement de Tripoli donc on a bien
on voit bien que les lignes de clivage
Est-Ouest ne sont plus si clair il y a
un affrontement politique et il y a une
grande fragmentation du pays donc ce qui
définit j'allais l'A très bien tout à
l'heure la Libye aussi c'est que les
alliances ne sont pas idéologiques elles
sont en changeantes donc les gens font
de la politique finalement bon au sens
pas forcément au sens noble du terme
parce que c'est pas dans l'intérêt ni du
bien commun ni de la majorité de la
population libelle mais ils savent je
dirais où sont leurs intérêts et pour
revenir aussi sur ce qui a été dit dans
le documentaire je crois que c'est
Claudia galzini qui dit finalement tout
le monde a perdu je pense qu'il y en a
qui ont pas perdu c'est effectivement
cette tasse politique cette tasse
politique qui depuis 2011 et rejeté par
la population et et détesté par une
immense partie de la population et
corrompue et effectivement ça a été très
bien dit Hassan Salamé le dit souvent
aussi c'est un système capitocratique
voilà et j'en viens à la dernière chose
que je voulais dire parce que c'est
important pour revenir aux médiations
c'est ce que vous disiez tout à l'heure
comment les Libyens ne peuvent pas avoir
ce regard vis-à-vis de leur classe
politique aujourd'hui après ce qui s'est
passé
tu payes l'addition sans forcément les
Libyens et c'est pour ça que l'immense
majorité de la population libyenne moi
j'ai participé à une avec le Centre
Polya luminaire pour lequel je travaille
il y a trois ans à
une série de réunions publiques ou l'ONU
nous avait mandaté on a fait 77 réunions
publiques et ce qui dégageait de toutes
ces réunions on a rencontré des milliers
de Libyens c'est que les gens veulent
des élections ils veulent changer de
classe politique alors j'y viens parce
que les élections
elles étaient prévues à la fin de
l'année 2021 en décembre 2021 si tout
était bien passé
la Libye aurait eu des élections pour
l'ensemble du territoire elles n'ont pas
eu lieu ces élections et c'était une des
solutions évidemment pour pour sortir de
cette crise et de faire de la Libye un
état et un seul c'était ça l'objectif
est-ce qu'on a une chose de voir ces
élections programmées assez rapidement
maintenant avec les médiations mises en
place notamment du côté des des Nations
Unies oui il y a une petite possibilité
de des élections en 2023
c'est simplement un corollaire de ce
qu'on a établi jusqu'ici le rôle des
États étrangers aucun État étranger
était sincèrement intéressé à mettre en
oeuvre des élections en 2021 mais on
vient d'établir qu'ils ont un rôle une
influence importante donc il suffirait
que des états plutôt rivaux comme la
Turquie d'un côté et l'Egypte se mettre
d'accord pour se débarrasser de la
classe de des élites actuelles pour que
d'un seul coup on assiste à des
élections relativement rapidement 6-9
mois donc ça c'est je trouve ça
intéressant c'est que
l'influence brute si vous voulez des
états et tellement importante que ça
marche dans les deux sens ça marche dans
le sens d'un blocage mais ça peut aussi
débloquer les choses assez rapidement
d'autant que Patrick l'a bien expliqué
l'immense majorité de la population
souhaite des élections donc les élites
ne tiendraient pas seul sans soutien
étranger je vois que c'était la France
elle avait vraiment essayé de pousser
l'organisation d'élection notamment
l'année dernière c'était vraiment
c'était vraiment une des une des
priorités de de l'Elysée mais la France
seule ne peut rien en Libye donc là
aussi on arrive ça en dit beaucoup sur
en fait le
manque d'influence le la capacité d'un
pays seul européen à pouvoir
influencer si les autres acteurs ne sont
pas exactement c'est la même longueur
d'onde oui je crois qu'il y a beaucoup
de choses à dire d'abord on va parfaire
l'histoire pourquoi les élections n'ont
pas eu lieu là aussi la communauté
internationale et nous avons une
responsabilité c'est
en novembre si mes souvenirs sont bons
2020 en septembre 2020 le Parlement qui
bien sûr ne voulait pas d'élection le
Parlement ce qu'il veut c'est rester en
place à Émile loi qui s'appelle la loi
numéro 1 qui est une loi qui qui
torpillait les élections c'est une loi
qui ne prévoyait que des élections
présidentielles donc elle était modelée
si je veux pour un homme fort pour le
maréchal leftar bon la communauté
nationale les Français les premiers mais
même l'envoyer spécial des Nations unies
dans un premier temps
applaudit cette loi sachant que cette
loi même fermer la porte aux élections
jamais à l'ouest on aurait accepté
effectivement effectivement des
exections présidentielles et la dernière
chose que je veux dire aussi aujourd'hui
pour parler d'avenir on a trois on a
trois paramètres on a effectivement
comme disait Jalal que les les
pays
régionaux et les grandes puissances se
mettent d'accord on a que les acteurs
locaux acceptent aussi de renoncer au
statut quo et on a aussi que le
médiateur des Nations Unies arrive à
reprendre en main quelque part un
processus politique pour l'instant où
c'est encore le nu qui qui en est chargé
donc voyez on a plusieurs choses et il
faut que ces trois je pense que ces
trois ces trois conjonctures puissent
être réunies pour pouvoir avoir des
élections et le médiateur des États-Unis
qui vient d'être nommé on va citer son
nom et c'est Abdoulaye Bathily qui est
d'origine sénégalaise vous l'avez dit
tout à l'heure et donc en grande partie
à lui il va revenir la tâche peut-être
de faire en sorte que ces élections
aient lieu peut-être vous l'avez vous
dit en 2023 ce sera peut-être l'occasion
de vous réinviter pour reparler de cette
situation en Libye en tout cas un grand
merci vraiment à tous les contre l'avoir
participé à ce débat de aujourd'hui pour
parler de ce pays qu'est la Libye après
le documentaire que nous vous
présentions aujourd'hui vos réactions ça
sera sur hashtag des Badoc sur Twitter
merci à sel massali qui m'a aidé comme à
la coutumée à préparer cette émission je
vous donne rendez-vous tout simplement
pour un prochain débat doc et ça sera
bien sûr avec son documentaire et son
débat à très bientôt
[Musique]